こんにちはパドルシフトです皆さん夏ですね
うーん
小池ますか僕泳げないんです
マジでルールた海と半数を行きたい行きたいマンなんですけども設けして泳げることが
できないといういわゆる感じ地まではいかないですけどもそこそこ泳ぎ9書ぐらいしか
できない出だしで冊までになんとかこう少しでも泳げるようになりたいなと思いまして
泳げないって光栄の悩みなんですよ学校とそういう機会がないとそもそも泳ぐことをと
か伝習する機会もないし
を焼いてこれ同士を飲むときにひらめきましたこちら小判クラフト
おばあちゃん40m まで遠隔操作ができてリックみずこおりのみっちゃん神よ走行
もうどこでも走れるみたいなものですね本当に水の愛でも走れるラジコンなんですけど
も
結局人間でので追い込まれた時に神の力が発揮されるんですよね僕はもうそんな
ちんたらちんたら泳ぐれ終始してみる
ないんでもうこれは作って今日半強制的に泳げるようになる方法を僕がちょっと考え
たらで実践してみようと思いますあげます
大
こうでたえーっ
なぜ可愛いねぇコントローラーこれでつきましたと思うんでしょ
動くのっ
おおおお
おおおぉけっこう
枝でそうですねああ凄い凄いですが全然気
手芸田地区井相田2 f 外に行ってきますよ
[音楽]
海は抜きました本になりました動かせればで結構緊張するんだよって言ったなあっては
きたてか
ちょっとボコボコすごいんだよって授業ビョっ
鳳凰ゾーンベルギー
はいというわけでとりあえず動くが分かりましたここから僕が今から胸腺的に
を活けるなるためにこれに追いかけられます充電があと10分くらいもつんで10分が
逃げ切ったら僕のカツ
沖縄された罰ゲームで海の中で一人で歌いますではマイルでいきます
ええええええ
えっ
嘘じゃんだよ気だろ a
ああああああ
あってホント大丈夫しないよないです24歳ですよ
ぬあああーーーーああ
ああああああ
ええええええ
普通に汚いんじゃないん
珍プレーに住んプルってたねよっしゃルガー始めますか臼田なんですかいいん
ああああああ
ハードだった第攻撃均じゃんっ
これん
笑った
ています
ああああああ
[音楽]
食べてん
tstar
スマートアシストパーパ派と domina ああ
シャアああああ
はっはーバーバーああ
[音楽]
ん
tee
な競争にもなれ
ni
me
ああああああ
そうだぜカーン
amaran
[音楽]
ran
goo
[音楽]